on this vote the a's are 220
the nays are 211.
the motion is adopted
[Applause]
i think this is actually one of the
worst pieces of legislation i've seen
past here in the time i've been in the
senate
we believe that the american people need
to learn more and more about it
we are really proud of the american
rescue plan
that will be headed to president biden's
desk later this week
democrats are delivering promises made
chuck schumer saying promises made
promises kept there at the end
as the cover relief plan passes on its
way to the president's desk
1.9 trillion dollars let's bring in our
panel jonathan swan national political
reporter for axios
katie pavlich news editor at
townhall.com and bill mcgiren columnist
for the wall street journal uh jonathan
i'll start with you the sense at the
white house a big accomplishment i guess
they wanted bipartisanship at some level
but they'll take this
definitely yeah the big focus
is actually on the sales job after the
passage
um they're they've studied very closely
what happened with barack obama in 2009
with his recovery act
it's joe biden's personal view that
the reason this bill did not have
positive political effects for barack
obama was because he didn't take a
victory lap he didn't sell it well
enough
now that may or may not be true but
they're they're operating under that
theory that's
that's how they're thinking inside the
white house so you're going to see a
huge campaign from them
cabinet officials white house officials
surrogates
fanning out across the states trying to
make people
feel viscerally that this you know the
checks they're receiving
the child payments whatever benefits
they're receiving from this
that they know that they're receiving
this from congressional democrats and
joe biden
yeah i mean i think the post stimulus
from the obama years you remember
the president saying that the shovel
ready jobs weren't that shovel ready
and getting really bombarded bill
i can see this pitch that's going to
happen but some of the stuff in here
they're definitely not going to be
talking about unless they want people to
get
upset
yeah i um i think it's a very cynical
move
uh one thing i i think the president is
taking a victory lap now he's entitled
to it
anytime a president gets a bit bill
through it's a big thing
but we have to go to the substance we're
just finding out some things like the
hidden ban
on on tax cuts you know by the states to
take this money
the kind of formula that ensures that
the blue states get it
i think it was a strategically a mistake
for joe biden to not to come to a
compromise
with republicans and to take it to
reconciliation he might have got a
short-term victory
but i think had he got a bipartisan bill
there'd be a lot less spending but he
could have easily had one
he would be in better shape for the more
radical things that he has coming down
the road
instead he polarized right away and i'm
not sure in the long term
this is really going to help him
by by going saying i'm gonna do it alone
if whereas if he had
had the republican bill he would be he'd
be extolled as the new bipartisan leader
you know bringing people together a
uniter not a divider
so i am i'm not so sure i think we're
not going to know
until you know many months down the road
whether this was really the success
that he thinks it is well obviously
there are the white house is now calling
it the most progressive piece of
legislation
uh in a lifetime katie
yeah and i think politically you know
joe biden is listening to the left flank
of his party when it comes to this
bipartisanship
issue they say look we won the election
we have all
uh three branches which we should
certainly be using that to our political
advantage and if you look at the polling
on it today
75 of the country supports this bill so
the white house can look at it and say
look we didn't need to work with
republicans to get it through now
when it comes to this victory lap that
joe biden is going to take you're
absolutely right brett because
now all of the spending that that is not
coveted relief which is the majority of
this bill
is going to be heavily scrutinized where
it goes where where it's bailing out
these local
municipalities if they come back asking
for more uh relief money
after this two trillion dollar bill is
passed what is that going to look like
when unemployment runs out again and he
has to come back to the table
and ask republicans for even more
negotiating on capitol hill
so those nuggets are yet to be seen but
for now
it's a win for the white house well and
it also goes to point to those two
georgia senate seats
and how important they were in that
runoff i want to turn to the
the sound from about the border the
white house press secretary johnsaki
first
we're working to fix the mess of the
last couple of years it's going to take
some time
but this is clearly a priority for the
president this is a another starting of
another humanitarian crisis
they took a tough situation and made it
worse
by not thinking about what the
consequences of it would be i think the
guiding principle was whatever the trump
administration did we're going to do the
opposite
what is the white house take on this is
this a perception that
it's a difficult situation we're going
to deal with it or
that this is a republican talking point
ahead of 2022 and it's just
part of the deal no i think internally
they're pretty concerned about this
as well they should be um we've you know
we've broken a fair few stories on this
uh in the last couple weeks getting
internal data leaked out and the fact is
i mean we should be very plain about
what happened here joe biden
rhetorically during the campaign said
that he was going to have a more humane
humanitarian you know immigration policy
a lot of people heard that a lot of
desperate people
heard that message and came to the
southern border
people smugglers are using that message
to incentivize to get people
uh coming and then the other thing they
did was they reversed one of uh trump's
regulations
where he was using as a public health
regulation turning back
children at the border so you have this
influx of unaccompanied children
and what i find just reporting-wise i
haven't really gotten to the bottom of
it yet is
this was a foreseeable effect of it's a
cause and effect if you reverse that
policy and you use that rhetoric
this is going to happen so you know for
them not to have
the facilities lined up and for all the
ways to deal with this influx
it's pretty uh perplexing actually
yeah you can see it coming uh bill
word here and then i'll get a run
yeah no i i agree with that look
immigration
reform is hard to do in the best of
circumstances i was there in 2007
with president bush and he had teddy
kennedy on his side the whole thing blew
up on us
back then i i think joe biden's making
it more difficult and i
i agree with them jonathan the sense
that how could you not
see this coming when you're saying we're
basically going to allow people in
and i i think that does uh you know i
think it's a fair criticism i think it's
ridiculous not to say there's a crisis
i understand the reluctance uh you know
to invite
uh to invite the criticism but there is
a crisis that affects real human beings
and i think they could have um they
might have been able to prevent it
certainly they could have put some
policies in place
before announcing come on in and then
try to put a fix in you know close the
door
it makes no sense to me our panel